what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to do a movie
reaction today for Starship Troopers
that's how I imagine they say it John
how are you I am doing well how are you
Greg doing great that's how I imagine I
say that it leaves my Paramount Plus
subscription in 10 hours so I was like
well we gotta knock this off the list
then full disclosure I'm pretty sure
when I was like seven years old so like
25 years ago I saw some of this movie
needless to say I can't tell you
anything about it other than I'm pretty
sure they kill a lot of big bugs in it
so it's pretty much gonna be like a
first time watching for me essentially
but John you've never seen this at all
right no I've seen some of the effects
pieces in person but that's about it
yeah it's gonna be a fresh fresh film
fresh film yeah because I know my dad
really liked this movie
I caught it in the background in his own
frame I experience growing up with it
the latest gentlemen leave a like that'd
be very much appreciated uh that would
that would help us out I guess also
subscribe click the notification Bell we
got more movie reactions rolling out we
are out of town at the moment and so we
will be back to the 20th so we're just
kind of trying to stockpile though the
list of things we did not cover and uh
full length Reaction watch along as we
sync up with your own copy of Starship
Troopers available for super sexy
rejects on our patreon page major major
thank you to all who have helped us have
great holidays by supporting us on our
patreon let's get into action people
young people from all over the globe are
joining up to fight for the future
doing my part I'm doing my part
I mean my part too oh God
source of the bug meteor attacks orbits
a twin star system whose brutal
gravitational forces produce an
unlimited supply of bug meteorites in
the form of this asteroid that's
horrifying
we break neck now and take you live to
clendafield where the invasion has begun
a planet
crazy it's like some Pitch Black [ __ ]
yeah
that's kind of like the muto from
Godzilla
wow what an opening
[Music]
I just go right into the camera it's
like a found footage movie
this is a Paul verhoven movie right yeah
okay Rico
Rico
Rico
pay attention and pH damn we talked
about the veterans how they took control
and imposed the stability that has
lasted for Generations since
you know these facts but if I taught you
anything of value Denise Richards wow
she's so ugly
the contrary opinion that violence never
solves anything
is wishful thinking at its worst people
who forget that always pay Suave
I doubt anyone here would recognize
civic virtue if it reached up and bit
you in the ass
you'll never get together now she was so
ugly I heard this movie was gross but
geez
good job my God
yikes it's embarrassing
cool
insect Society by human standards they
are relatively stupid but what have the
bugs done do they attack us
the heart
no gloves on anybody
a solid barf gag she just got hot
kink but Cyrano
go bug mom Cyrano
go bug mom
to go eat it
I sure hope you don't do anything like
that to me can't do human
yet Neil Patrick Harris you are
problematic
oh my god future football yes
wow it's the XFL everyone's going to the
dance aren't you well let's go over
tomorrow you're going to the fleet
Academy
[Applause]
not Bill Paxton you are hitting on her
[Applause]
ow damn that's a very colorful film say
Buenos Aires tigers
Denise Richards you don't give two [ __ ]
you're drifting
got it get your head in the game this
was in friends as a reoccurring
character
[Applause]
can't get over that it's so cool it's
the coolest flips are cool
let's go Casper Vending
[Applause]
that's right you still have a girlfriend
I'd rather take 10 Lashes in Public
Square than see you ruin your life it's
a term of service I just want to get out
on my own into space and a war
god that is a conflict which one do you
go for depending on who the camera's on
I think she's the better looking no
Johnny how come we never been together
can we just be friends this
dude
friend zone Troopers well my parents are
against it what would you do if you were
me
figuring things out for yourself is the
only Freedom anyone really has use that
freedom make up your own mind Rico he
told me to make up my mind so that's
what I'm gonna do
[Laughter]
what are the bugs doing though
you know there's just existing they're
inflicting tyranny are they they're
taking our jobs Gene what are they doing
here this is the address yeah we know
each other from the game
well maybe I'll see you at the Academy
yeah who knows do you know you would go
for that guy with that haircut he looks
like Chris Catan militaryism
great thing it's a great thing dude I
love Wars authoritarianism great thing
great things thank you I'm gonna be a
pilot
for you got games in theory
Game Theory
it's a game Game Theory
let's make a vow
no matter what
will always be friends
your friendship at risk
yeah man that's what the bugs are doing
tearing us apart no we're Zion that's
all there is to it it may look bad but
if that's the worst you suffer then
that's fine I won't quit
[Laughter]
it's my decision I made it you walk out
that door you are cut off young man you
understand me all right that's it you
are cut off
I love this definition
distinguishing Citizen and civilian yeah
I'm gonna miss you
I'm gonna miss you too I love you
oh that's me no
ouch
[Laughter]
just like that high school's over
[Music]
fully automatic burrito wants to hold it
citizen rule
[Music]
yes right over that gun
it's hilarious
every school kid knows that her records
are dangerous
good censorship the antenna had already
been chosen by other colonists arachnids
would you like to know more
that's enough for one day definitely
some RoboCop in this movie's DNA
[Music]
plants are brown yeah buddy who thinks
they got what it takes to knock me down
yeah I do sir that's the spirit
ouch
you go that far
you're right son sir yes sir it's smart
ow
oh
so dumb who's next
reporting for Duty sir no way
Pacific living requested transfer from
Fort Cronkite to this training unit
sorry
stock makes youth
that's the kind of guy who makes squad
leader that's my job you're talking
about
Street Fighter no she looks like Cami
nicely done Clancy Brown Colonel guile
wins I joined up to get out on my own
and you had to tag along
I joined the mobile infantry because of
you
you're saying you didn't I'd be honored
Rico
hi
much better
thanks squad leader Rico then I got you
don't
know
it isn't about that it's about who's the
best hey
ah there's your squad leader
what are you doing yes
worst form of trading
uh he gonna remember that the enemy
cannot push a button if you disable his
hand
you know Rico from Buenos Aires what's
his story
it's here because of a girl
these people just not have sex drives
what's going on here
everyone's used to the human anatomy in
this future
sometimes I think I won't make it
but then I think about what you're doing
then I try harder
it's not the first take of that butt
shot
you guys this is like the perfect right
wing world fascistopia I love it
I still don't know what the bugs do
that's really that bad
you know other than exists existing
Andy's got such like a pristine Sheen to
it all I love it
deploying wings
it's terrifying
sweet Elysium
[Music]
now this is POD racing how come you're
in such a good mood huh because today I
get to fly that
Dizzle what are you doing here I'm the
guy who's gonna teach you to flatten
this crate already
scrape your Fender three meters from
object
[Music]
I bet you're greatest hundreds of people
oh just do it don't exceed Port speed or
what or they revoke your flight status
and
your career is in my hands
how does it feel
are they really getting shot I think
they're getting electrocuted
she's clearly the one for you man man
they're defending
me whole play and you can score
cover me you could score Flip Flip
[Music]
wow
[Music]
thanks buddy
[Music]
oh yes dual wielding double fist in
[Music]
flag captured Rico wins I couldn't have
done it without you [ __ ]
friends
yeah you playing the long game
hi Johnny God this is so hard who do you
go for
flight
this is the real conflict of the movie
up with him
I mean Johnny
let's give him some space guys what kind
of right-wing [ __ ] is this she
should be settling down with him kill
all those bugs this is not a satire
anymore
go with the backup this what are you
doing today
fire team with me next team in 10
seconds
expect you to do better burhoven has
such an interesting way of doing
political commentary I know it just it
just creates the world and commits to it
and doesn't even like talk about it
just lets the world demonstrate itself
yeah
[Music]
it's my helmet it's all screwed up don't
take it off Disney put what's the
problem
whenever something goes wrong it's
always you don't take your helmet off
dude oh no oh [ __ ]
that's
damn ain't no medic for that Rico did
you give the recruit permission to
remove his helmet
sir yes sir Breckenridge reported a
helmet malfunction and I asked him to
show it to me sir are you rated Hank
Sergeant we've already lost two recruits
over this incident
I'll be back we'll try administrative
punishment
oh put him in the stocks
I'm gonna whip him this is a very
entertaining movie yeah for failure to
abide by safety regulations during a
live fire exercise
for negligence which contributed to the
death of a teammate black man whipping
the white man hey hell yeah
ten lashes
they carry out the sentence oh they all
have to be present for it
[Music]
I'll try not to enjoy this too much yeah
and lashes geez there's a gravity field
out there gravity at 225 and Rise report
captain we're in the path of an
unidentified object moving toward us at
high speed profile suggests an asteroid
ma'am
oh yeah let's get some bugs in space
[Music]
oh dang
50 people just died contact please tell
them there's a loose asteroid headed
their way Communications are down ma'am
they're gone oh no I was hoping it would
be all right if I came home
come home
and meet I'm sorry I've been in
need I don't talk like that you just
come on home talk things out
I'll tell you I told you so we love you
son oh they're gonna get killed aren't
they yeah
he's got to get motivated somehow
Millions there a city in Ruins is that
Geneva the meteor was shot out of orbit
By Buck plasma that derived from
clendathu the arachnid's home planet
[Music]
God thank God they were away yeah yeah
[Laughter]
Buenos Aires has been wiped off the
Earth
wowie to ensure that human civilization
not insect dominates this galaxy now and
always yes dominance is the key your
basic arachnid Warrior isn't too smart
but you can blow off a limb
it's still 86 percent combat effective
here's a tip aim for the nerve stem and
put it down for good his hair is not as
blunt I'm from Buenos Aires and I say
kill them all yeah
I feel like we've
maybe we've seen so much Doctor Who
I'm just like I just don't feel like the
Bucks today I know they just need a
habitable home world where they won't
fly into ours at random like are they
really that bad
Xander you remember Johnny
this is the part that's best for both of
us Johnny wait I didn't forget a
lieutenity's mobile infantry you got
something to say about the mobile
Infantry
think you heard me you want to make
something of it yes
football do it shirtless football
come on what's he gonna do
[Applause]
come on
mobile infantry and Fleet don't mix
doomed from the start
[Music]
this movie has an insane production yeah
man
this looks gorgeous
it's like so many costumes and set
pieces
straight man I thought this move was
gonna be them mainly just killing bugs I
know
but there's so much more commentary than
I expected yeah I mean most all the bug
kills thus far like an hour if we
haven't even got into them yeah they're
all in either like laboratory settings
or propaganda videos yeah
[Music]
cheese man still looks great drop is 35
complete man
wow
[Music]
oh someone made a mistake
oh no get out of there
oh yeah that's chaos
whoa
a lot of dead humans look at all these
extras my God they're they're just
running right into battle oh is this the
beginning of the movie was I mean it
looks kind of like it although it's much
darker than that was
[Applause]
up
holy God that is terrifying
[Music]
[Music]
wowie because you ain't got to worry
about radiation in this future
[Music]
fire
oh [ __ ]
wow looks really hard to kill them got
an aim at the nerve cortex
that is so many bugs what are we doing
I don't know
oh yeah sure why not do that that's a
strategy
more than just yourself killed
oh my God
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
God I would just rely on grenades oh
oh no she was so nice Glenda
[Music]
this is flat this is worth a [ __ ] so
fast play it get out of here
let's keep filming just keep filming
whatever
the people the world needs to know
that's clever to get it on the other
side I'll buy that for a dollar I love
that the camera man I think it's great
to get that perspective of the cameraman
yeah just like get that shot
get out of here now
that was Casper Van Dean at the
beginning
oh man
yikes oh
foreign
bugs frankly I find the idea of a bug
that thinks offensive
[Laughter]
is small-minded man what's going on with
that whole psychic thing that's got to
come in especially with the hive mind
idea
[Music]
it's all your fault
why they declare Rico deceased he's
right here
Star Wars
that's cool
see you later bye
oh oh
that was a nice three days in there
sounds relaxing hopefully the bugs don't
come in and destroy it all you want the
job huh I wouldn't mind
that guy's a walking dead so I hear you
lieutenants are real nut Buster oh
that would be you no one talks about the
lieutenant that way
saved my life mine too oh he's the
priest yeah yeah
who's that iron inside yeah
[Music]
everyone fights no one quits
you don't do your job I'll shoot you
they were just trying to have a parade
just now that's all there's marching
through town they're just doing their
thing did I miss some line in the
beginning
tells you why they're so bad like yeah
you interacted and they're gonna kill
you but it's just like leave them alone
much easier to kill them during the day
[Music]
[Applause]
it was screaming I was in pain guys
don't waste your bullets it takes like 4
000 bullets to kill one
and you guys clearly just take the spray
approach
that is a nuclear rocket
I got
[Music]
oh oh here we go
you need another nuke oh yeah I remember
that shot from the trailers when I was a
kid
I did remember that shot
oh no no that's your punching arm no I
liked her
get on top of him that's smart
learn to ride it
it's like a boss level yeah it really
doesn't make a great arcade game
[Music]
Jam a nuke down in
[Music]
hurry up Rico get off there
that's far enough away
[Music]
oh yeah oh he's not getting
disintegrated that's for Buenos Aires
yes
I need a cork you're it until you're
dead or do I find somebody better
promotion what about this
looks like I'm your girl sir
I do have great chemistry all three of
them they should have a three-way
[Applause]
have fun
sir yes sir come on Corporal ah no I
don't do that anymore I remember when
you used to Dance come on do I have to
pull ring
oh come on man you once asked me for
advice you want some now yes sir never
pass up a good thing
I've been watching you since school and
you're an idiot son
[Music]
finally
get that Casper Van dip
[Music]
I love you Johnny
[Music]
oh he didn't say it back you're moving
out there's been his best golf in
general one on planet P so get your [ __ ]
wired and report in 10 minutes yes sir
who's that with you
Glory sir make it 20 minutes
Wing Man of the Year in contact with
General Owen no sir not even the
transponder signal it's these Canyons go
to Higher Ground sir
all good Wings
this is roughneck 2-0
I feel like you straight up sacrificed
that guy
[Music]
mercy kill I'd expect anyone in this
unit to do the same for me
will I would love to be in this war
gross
jeez
dirty bugs came in right well they're
having ciao
oh
really what does that look like to you
Rico
oh
like a bug was in his brain sir
oh
you just put your [ __ ] hand in there
oh
that's blood already sucked his brains
out
Jake Busey did not sign up for this we
should just shoot me
just a little out of his mind sir
space dementia
those are cool outfits yeah the helmets
and all that stuff like that's a lot of
bugs
no that's an impossible situation
[Music]
oh those got to help
that is so many bugs how does this all
look as good as it does
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
oh wow
I know ammo has never been an issue
[Music]
yeah
yep
Yep this place called sir we need pickup
now watch your position come down on
this transmission so The Outpost that's
crazy I hope you have a crazy pilot ow
you have a crazy pilot
[Music]
Christ
oh my God this is an impossible
situation it's a nightmare
further
[Music]
so yeah we're way faster
feel that slash yeah
oh
guys just let him go just get the get
out of there what are you wasting your
time for
that's a crazy pilot
they ain't covered fire fall back
this is the rescue
hold on
Michael Ironside oh why are you always
Dying Michael iron son
oh my God
nah you're gonna have to kill him dude
put him out of his misery he remembers
orders
nice
[Music]
oh damn
foreign
[Music]
oh she's getting a painful ass death
put her in the back to tank she'll be
fine
no come on she's the best
[Music]
let's go get a board
[Music]
you too
[Music]
damn it
oh jeez that's horrific
Johnny I'm done
no you're gonna be all right this oh man
because I got to have you oh oh that's
really sad say it back buddy
[Music]
oh no
that is sad maybe Denise Richards will
take him back especially now she's
concerned about his feelings it's her
Duty
attention on dick
wow she's getting like a full-on funeral
representative of all the soldiers no
one gets a full-on funeral
[Music]
Burial at space
[Music]
Jesus
[Laughter]
and every day I have to make decisions
that send hundreds of people like you to
their deaths that's what the mobile
infantry is good for
going back to pee
capture that brain
you're still gonna be friends everyone
fights no one quits don't do your job
I'll kill you myself do you get me
welcome to the roughneck Rico's
Roughnecks alliteration
[Music]
they really should plan better they've
been through this yeah like come on guys
what does a brain bug do it controls
them all it's like the queen it's the
hive mind yeah
no all of his love interests are going
to die
[Music]
wow that's horrifying
damn the details yeah that's beautiful
[Music]
oh
bummer oh
she's dead
[Music]
Space Mountain
foreign
[Music]
you breaking up
[Music]
oh get out get out what's your name
address and birthday
that's right hey good all right let's go
let's rock and roll now 42 East 118
situation is I repeat
the situation is extremely hostile
here we go whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
bug sucks out the brains does it like
take all the memories and everything I
guess it seems like they're yeah they're
like learning sort of how to anticipate
what the humans will do
and learning what the humans want she's
still alive
how do you know
I don't know how I know but I know
[Music]
roughneck 2-0
proceed on Mission I need two volunteers
buddy the main the main people will
leave
who assumes command
yeah uh that is disgusting I'm pretty
sure I've seen an image of this creature
before I have seen this creature in
person before have you yeah damn what
effects house was that
it's so cute oh my God that is
disgusting I feel a little nauseous
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God
sweet darling yeah
[Music]
that knife
throw it throw it yes
should not be used that hand
[Laughter]
she would not be holding up her arm like
that
says it's way too much not armed she's
not even like responding
foreign
[Music]
oh no no walking dead priest guy
[Music]
order
Duck and Cover why would you stop to
look stop stop
saved by a cave-in life made the
decision for him got rid of that one guy
got rid of that girl man
now they're both Carmen
oh no
ah poor guy it's in pain it's a Fray
yeah
foreign we are terrorizing these
creatures xenophobia
fear is the ultimate power
[Applause]
the drill instructor named Zim who
captured a brain hey
good for him thank you sir that would be
private sir
here I am private yes sir we had to get
the voter to go to combat that's that's
that's kind of neat
Federal scientists are working around
the clock to probe its secrets
we will defeat it
[Applause]
this is the captain speaking
soldiers like private Ace Levy and
lieutenant John Rico
[Music]
dope
Paul verhoven
wow that was fun that was a delight
that was a movie that was cool what'd
you think John I I was uh a roller
coaster ride that was quite enthralling
is yeah like you said I I guess I it it
out at the outset I expected something
more along the lines of like you know
the third act but for the whole movie so
I I appreciated how much they let you
live in this world and how it sort of
just presents everything to you and sort
of leaves it up to you to kind of
interpret how it's
you know coming at the material because
I think this is based on a book and I
think the book is said to be a lot more
unironically what this movie is doing
um but yeah uh
I had a blast this was fun from from
start to finish and I appreciate the sly
way in which Paul verhoven Works in his
commentary to these different movies and
I thought the cast was great too
the cast was great Casp Casper Van Deen
man where's Casper Van Deen why is where
where's the Casper science gonna gonna
happen
um well the recommendations on Amazon
are
Starship Troopers 3 which seems like
Casper Van Deen returns yes that's the
one older yeah Starship Troopers
invasion Starship Troopers traitor of
Mars that's like an animated movie where
he looks like snake pliskin I I feel
like maybe they lost sight of the
commentary I haven't just became about I
have an absolute feeling that this
franchise became what the first movie
was trying to comment
yeah yeah yeah totally is I I don't know
I have I have no idea but it's just
impression that I'm sort of because yeah
it's one of those things where if it
feels satirical
um but also
in the in the kind of like kind of like
RoboCop
um there's a lot of Robocop in here yeah
but kind of like how RoboCop has a
commentary but it doesn't treat it with
a wink at the audience in a way it's
almost like he made a propaganda film
yeah you know yeah and I think that's
kind of the the cool approach to it
because it's also like an entertaining
cheesy campy movie like there's a lot of
ways you can look at it as like just a
fun sci-fi movie that is as much as it's
like a propaganda it's like it deals
with all kinds of things of like fascism
there are certain words I have the
hardest time pronouncing
authoritanianism authoritarianism
yeah yeah and military conquest uh yeah
though those words militarism militarism
yeah militarism and and the way we like
recruit uh people so young I mean I
guess it helps that all these high
school seniors look like their college
seniors but uh but yeah well they had a
good gloss to it with everyone it was
like the perfect world of what you know
uh and if if I wasn't aware I don't
think it would have any
I don't it's only more obvious to me
because I'm aware Paul verhoven made it
yeah yeah versus you're like I didn't
know it I'd be like what is this
like yes this saying this is cool or I
might have just picked up on the Sci-Fi
stuff
um whereas like the propaganda stuff I'm
like like really is the commercials that
that make it that really shine a light
that this is a a satire commentary on it
yeah they bring the irony front and
center especially by the end when you
have like even bigger bigger shinier
titles and bigger shinier ships and guns
and then they're like torturing this
creature you know with all this
triumphant music playing like I think
that that kind of highlights what's
happening under the surface well also
the
the other than Neil Patrick Harris the
characters are likable
and they don't seem that bad they don't
seem like bad people you know what I
mean so as much as there's the
commentary on it which is something I
might just go into the form the societal
conditioning and the influencing of the
mindset you know uh sure it can whereas
like freaking Neil Patrick Harris is
like straight up turning into like
experimental Nazis
you know uh but look Casper Van Dean and
um I don't know that actress's name I
swear I've seen her a thousand times
though yeah I mean I've been trying to
place it this whole time at a role in
friends of Rick she was in a play with
Joey Tribbiani oh snap she's great yeah
um
yeah I I thought she was awesome and I
like I like the tone of it a lot it's
really funny and self-aware and
and I even enjoyed Denise Richards Dina
Meyer Dina Meyer
oh yeah yeah Denise Richard is good too
in this that's right she's in birds and
she's she's jigsaw's wife that's or no
no not jigsaw's wife she's she's the
she's uh massage she's like the one of
the investors oh yeah she gets killed
she gets that horrible uh yeah three uh
spoilers if you were planning on binging
it dies in three they're going I swear
you're inside but I can't I can't quite
I don't yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and a bunch of other faces you've
seen a thousand times I like the
relationship between the the core three
it's like a fourth guy there but I don't
really remember much better
like Jake Bucy
Dita Meyer Dina Meyer and uh I like the
chemistry between them I like the
90s High School romance love triangle
situation going on I thought that was
fun and yeah the effects still hold up
really well like it's gonna this looks
incredible killer production design this
looks amazing for when it was made like
this this is It's a testament to real
movie Magic to me because this was like
watching Jurassic Park again or
something where you're sitting there
going like man
the budget must have been insane but you
also know exactly where to put
Miniatures you knew where to put your
physical effects you knew how to reuse
all those corpse bodies really cleverly
without calling too much attention to it
and then when the CG needs to be there
for the most part it looks pretty great
like the only real CG effects where I
was like this could be a little bit
better is when you know like the brain
alien at the end is so like Smooth I
feel like those textures maybe don't
read as well but for the most part like
it's it's really well assembled but it
doesn't pull me out of the movie It's
I'm aware because because the movie's so
cheesy too that it
so I mean it's a real movie still it's
still a real film it's not I I thought I
was just walking into pure cam Fest sure
you know not that I'm like oh this is a
real serious thing uh yeah I just
thought I was gonna walk into it because
when I heard it was two hours in like
two hours that's a long time and I feel
like it's a little I still feel like
it's a little too long a little light
look it's like it could have been like
20 minutes or later yeah yeah um but I I
still think that they they made an
actual film where I was invested in the
story
and I I did kind of care about the
characters for the most part like I was
really bummed when Dina died when you
got killed I was like what that sucks
that really bumped me out yeah no
absolutely like like they're good at
making you root for them and I think
they they did wisely to pull in a a
classic story uh because you know it's
like you're I think it's part of the
greater soup of what's happening in a
movie like this where like yeah
especially it doesn't betray its
perspective we are humans watching this
so we're watching it from the human
perspective so they're going to have
endearing relationships and they're
going to be in different qualities to
them and I think making it that you're
spending most of your time with these
private characters and you're watching
as um as Rico gets promoted through the
ranks but you know you're on the ground
level and I think that bolsters it like
you said is feeling like an actual movie
like it's treated like an actual war
movie but yeah you have like the just
the right amount of Camp to sell the
heightened sci-finess of it all without
it being silly and I think too they use
like the fact that uh the the Denise
Richards character uh Carmen is you know
becoming a pilot on this ship that looks
exactly like an imperial ship from Star
Wars like is uh I feel like those little
things help to kind of again betray
what's really going on but I think it's
a good choice that they don't
betray the characters too much by
overriding them with the author real you
know perspective of you know the the
themes and stuff like that not to say
it's like I feel like this is a movie
that has a lot of those themes on hand
but it's not like a hundred percent
committed to being like no this is an
allegory that's going to teach you
something about fascism and how the
mechanics of the military-industrial
complex work like it's commenting on
that stuff but it's also yeah like you
said having fun it's also really
imaginative it's also really well
constructed like it's a little bit of
everything and that's I think what makes
it so satisfying is because then on top
of all that you can go oh wait this
actually does have something of a brain
underneath all the machismo and all the
goo oh I think I think the the
insightfulness of what they're
commenting on is is kind of resonant
throughout the whole movie right down to
Casper Van Dean's Rico character just
the evolution that he has of
someone wanting to like spoiled rich kid
who wants to join the military to make
something of himself and then the way
his
the way he morphs over time into the
cold-blooded perfect Soldier by the end
of the weird side yeah it's cool like
it's not cool it's it's sad it's fleshed
out and how they did it but what I like
about the approach is
if it's made in a way that's not
demonstrating
that it's it's a clever film because
it's not
it doesn't feel like it's pro-war and
pro-violence no and
because if in fact in a lot of ways it's
it kind of feels like it's the opposite
of that yeah yet they make it in the way
they execute it was to make it like it's
a pro war movie well so that's what's
smart about it yeah like there's so much
that is really cool and and you have all
these great little uh interstitial
propaganda pieces and news items to
bolster the that attitude but when
you're really in the midst of the
fighting it it's pretty hellish like you
know for as height as it is like more to
them coming out yeah it sucks like those
battle scenes and and the gore gags and
the way people are getting mangled and
mutilated and disintegrated and melted
and like it's it's it's pretty nasty and
then when you get to the end you have
the brain sucker alien like it's really
gross and icky you know so I feel like
they they knew where to put
the real fun stuff
and it's still fun as a viewer to watch
you know the military action when it
really takes hold but I feel like those
scenes especially aren't played for fun
and that's part of why it it works it's
like it's one of those I feel like
movies before a certain point
with messaging and I guess you know
ham-fisted movies have always existed
but I feel like this is one that kind of
allows you the viewer to pick that up or
not you know in the way it portrays
things so you could probably watch this
and be laggy yeah let me go enlist right
now you know but you could also watch
this and be like
what did the bugs do though you know I
mean I was watching it the whole time
going what did that what did the bugs do
I don't know what the bugs did that were
so bad to
it's so bad that we have to go across
space to go and wipe them out and I
understand that yeah it's like they've
got these little meteorites hurling our
way but I'm like look at all this
technology we could easily deflect one
of those you know we could deal with
that you know
yeah it seems like it's like we we want
the violence and that's kind of what
they're learning in the school yeah yeah
it's like we want it we want the
violence I think there is an interesting
commentary to be had here but it's also
if you want to just watch it as like a
fun
like exploited flick I think you can do
that too because it is a fun movie
that's the magic of verhovah yeah I know
RoboCop has that for sure and show girls
and Showgirls especially he knocked it
out of the park there that's why I made
a bunch of films following Showgirls uh
yeah no I I think did he do Basic
Instinct too is that him maybe he's
please come back I want to say I forget
which ones he's done because I don't
know if it was imitative phase against
it because he's like I'm like watching
this made me miss okay so he's he's done
some some stuff recently but like this
made me miss maybe change their [ __ ]
around how's this working yeah it
doesn't separate things quite as
intuitively he did do basic NC yeah okay
yeah yeah yeah
like Total Recall yeah
if I wasn't so sure he was liberal
well yeah he's great at taking the end
RoboCop for the first time I saw that I
had a similar experience where I was
expecting like oh this is just gonna be
cool you know this is just gonna be some
cool schlocky hyper violent police
Thriller but you know like the police
are also a problematic organization and
that movie doesn't shy away from that or
the interplay between you know uh uh the
worst parts of capitalism and you know
force and Order and all those things and
and this also does that like I loved the
distinction between uh what is it
Citizen and uh civilian civilian yeah
and the way that they're using that in
school almost as a sociological sort of
thing uh but using that as the seed to
you know indoctrinate these kids you
know that whole thing about it actually
discouraged me you know like really kind
of uh uh creating this enticement of
these kids through that and then you
hear the I think that Motif has echoed
again when they say like you know
Consignment guarantees citizenship and
your conscription you know like joining
up guaranteeing citizenship and I feel
like immediately I thought like oh okay
you join our military we will make you a
citizen but no no no it's actually
legitimizing you as an already canonized
citizen you know like this is the way to
be a true citizen is to be a patriot is
to go out and fight you know yeah and
it's clever now the movie's very I
thought the movie was really clever and
I thought it had uh some cool action in
it infinite amount of bullets that you
just spray relentlessly
it's like non-stop never reload I
thought the costumes were really cool
too oh dude those helmets and yeah the
the especially the battle gear
sick yeah it was really it was it was
cool it was it was not exactly uh what I
was expecting no not at all actually
yeah like the last half it was
um and I was more I was more into it the
first half and I was the last half at
least because it's a really well
realized world and yeah I enjoyed going
through all the different you know you'd
go through all the different uh
institutions and ranks and places in
your your seeing so many pockets of how
Society exists now and two like they're
from you got all these people with these
like Hispanic names who are all these
like white kids and stuff so like it had
an interesting
I I almost wanted to know more about how
the world works now because you know it
seemed like the country boundaries
weren't the same as they are in our
version of the world so it seems just
like an it's one of those movies too
where the world build uh without having
to do all of it in a very in your face
way like there are just details about
the world that are interesting that
again are yours to catch or not catch
and uh and yeah it's like part of me was
like I want to spend time just sort of
knowing what Earth is like in this day
and age because yeah their designs were
really interesting what was the the so
the book itself is supposed to what were
you saying earlier that stood out to me
that the book itself is supposed to be
more
um like it's sincere in it and this is
making the movie took the approach of of
mocking it in a way or making fun of it
in a way yeah kind of warping it inside
out and making it a commentary on the
kind of fascism the book was essentially
demonstrating you know a more
straightforward sort of way is how it's
always been been broke down to me now
that I've seen the movie you know I'm
sure there's a very in-depth you know
video essay about that but that's always
what I've been sort of eluded by other
people
so here's a fun fact for you from imdb
oh let's do this
um
that uh
uh ver Hoven and cinematographer josta
vacano shot the co-ed shower scene in
the nude themselves on a dare from Dina
Meyer what uh on the day of the shoot
for Hoven I have asked to cast to a
little fashion show without fashion so
that can get comfortable being naked
when the cast is reluctant to disrover
Hoven asked them what the big deal was
to which my responded Paul if it's no
big deal why don't you do it quite
unexpectedly verhoven got undressed as
well as vicano who had been raised in a
nudity Camp after an initial shocked
then van Dean reporter yelled oh God
Dino why and a good laugh from the cast
The Scene was sold without problems that
seemed so distracting because I feel
like
half of you guys have to be like super
horny right now we are not your young
blood or showering a bunch of attractive
woman right like you created somehow the
most mature shooting environment because
none of us watching this either able to
be like nope this is normal
which good for them in the future I
guess uh uh you know uh sexual sociology
and politics are much more calm in this
future
because yeah they got co-ed everything
oh here we go there's an interesting
quote
um why are you doing a right-wing
fascist movie verhoven was asked he
replied if I tell the world that a
right-wing fascist way of doing things
doesn't work then no one will listen to
me so I'm going to make a perfect
fascist World everyone is beautiful
everyone is shiny everyone has big guns
and fancy ships but it's only good for
killing [ __ ] bugs yeah it is yeah
that is the world that he created yeah
yeah he's succeeded I mean that's the
way we treat him when we were going to
War 2 just crush them like they're bugs
crushed them like they're bugs and we
are you know the elite we're beautiful
and we are Mighty and yeah we're shiny
we will come and bring the lights to
whatever we touch our boots down on
uh wow this was crazy yeah man so many
trivias
well
guys I thought this was a really fun
movie with a much more interesting take
with a production design it still helds
up really well but some fun performances
to be had and I wonder what the sequels
ultimately pan out to be better than
some schlockfest so we'll watch them all
are they good are they highly revered
uh you know maybe part three is okay the
guy if they got van Deen back
I doubt it which I've seen him in person
okay so they have made a direct Starship
Troopers too
okay yeah these must be straight to part
three straight to DVDs right God
1997. damn 12 12
audience audience score that's a bummer
how is it so bad
that is so bad the the critics score is
higher that's 33 Starship Troopers three
50 critic score but but 19 audience
score but the caveat is only six critics
reviewed each of these movies oh yes so
so you have a way larger pool of uh
viewer reviews okay Starship Troopers
one not as as fresh on both accounts
Starship Troopers invasion the animated
one
is better liked by audiences for sure
oh traders of Mars sound
is it cost effective these days to do
these CG movies for stuff like this I
have no idea oh but Casper Van Dean and
Dina Meyer came back to do voices that's
cool so maybe her character lives I
guess maybe yeah maybe they'll do some
retcon oh he's got the eye patch yeah
damn Rico
I'm not sure we should watch them all we
should report back
Troopers binge guys that's right we will
rank them all and let you know which
one's the best God Denise Richards yeah
man back in the Heyday it was like I did
not know I did not realize you you were
the queen that's right man just before
Undercover Brother
she is before still pretty hot yeah no
she's she's a little little plastic
surgery it happens it happens it happens
it's now more than ever it happens when
you're in this world when you're on
planet Earth and you're a woman in
Hollywood a little over Botox you know
you know what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do what's the one I'm saying
do you know do you know what Dina my
I don't think you're right about that
you are hey hey hey hey she's aged
gracefully she looks good still but she
looks natural
yeah gray gray it's got some Grays going
on it's all good rock that silver rock
that silver oh Denise Richards are still
friends dude
all right let's get them all back
together difficult to choose reunion
I know and especially back then they're
both so electric they're both they both
had it it's real you know
that is the perfect like they live in
he goes like you go to Harvard the Ulta
he's got all the money yeah I know it
was in the best part of the capitalist
Society Embraces at all go to war fight
for your country doesn't it that's a
wild movie it's kind of uh yeah yeah
it's like the whole time I was like I
don't know what these bugs did
just because it's out here being it
doesn't sound like being bugs don't go
bother them that's it and if they come
your way deal with that but it just felt
like doesn't need to be anymore like why
they don't even fight I don't I don't
care why they're fighting there's no
need for them to fight that's seen one
of their I wonder I truly wonder if
those were real roaches where the kids
that one shower the kids are stomping on
the roaches and it may reminded me of
Men In Black that whole like you don't
start nothing it ain't gonna be nothing
you know well then when they're
um like when the cameraman too is also
like zooming in like when the person's
being killed and they're just like
[ __ ] recording up close just reminded
me a nope like just yeah that uh
more cells what can you do yeah whatever
you do don't stop filming I wonder if
they had the I I really wonder if those
roaches were real they're they're rules
about that
probably There are rules about bug
actors on screen you can't kill bugs on
screen alrighty guys well what do you
think of Starship Troopers leave your
thoughts down below
subscribe leave a like Hey listen to the
patron of the day shout out
Andrew Hayes we said who the hell are we
shouting out for Starship Troopers and
uh we ain't have to look at the list we
said who will we want on our team to go
out there and kill some bugs I'm gonna
kill some big bucks
Starship Troopers Andrew Hayes over here
you just if you know this guy short
stocky fella he can go in there run you
can see him running up that hill with
his tiny little legs
punch you in the face
get some that's Andrew Hayes out there
fighting some bugs man just had to
survive a bug apocalypse dude Andrew uh
I never hear from you anymore but you
stay pledged uh at the at that one of
our highest levels forever that's just a
loyal citizen of the reject nation and
the kind of person you want as part of
your army when you're traveling across
space trying to murder some creatures
that that they deserve it they
absolutely did everything so Andrew hope
you have a merry Christmas say hi to
your family for me and you better have a
damn good new year because if you don't
I'm kicking in that door
saying quit having a [ __ ] Year and have
a great year have a glow up
a love
use
[Music]